son los primeros arrestos que se conocen
por la muerte de 39 personas en un
centro de detención de migrantes de
México la justicia local emitió unas
seis órdenes de captura dirigidas a dos
agentes de seguridad privada tres
agentes del instituto de inmigración y
quien presuntamente inició la
conflagración cinco han sido arrestados
y no se ha precisado la responsabilidad
o el cargo de la aprehensión que falta
la empresa de seguridad encargada del
puesto de control migratorio también
será objeto de sanciones se le retirará
el permiso de operación y se le impondrá
una multa económica esto sucederá de
manera paralela con el proceso que
desarrolla la fiscalía para investigar
la responsabilidad de la compañía en el
siniestro incluso ya solicitamos el
Instituto Nacional de Migración recibir
el contrato con esta empresa y a partir
de mañana elementos del servicio de
Protección Federal asumirán las labores
de seguridad en las estaciones
de la estación migratoria de Ciudad
Juárez mientras las pesquisas avanzan
los familiares de las víctimas lloran a
sus seres queridos en El Salvador la
esposa de uno de los fallecidos Clama
por justicia
Yo espero que se haga justicia porque no
es justo que mueran tanto inocentes que
van o sea por luchar por la familia pues
para que vivan mejor para que tengan el
pan de cada día en su casa que no le
falte nada y y hacer eso pues yo siento
que es injusto porque pudieron ver
ayudado pudieron ver ayudado y no no lo
hicieron y que se haga justicia el
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador prometió que no habrá impunidad
ante estos hechos y que se castigará los
responsables entre los muertos se
encuentran ciudadanos colombianos
venezolanos hondureños y guatemaltecos